hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the round four of
the Sun we see this tournament someone
in the comment section suggested that
it's actually pronounced Sun wastages
tournament so if that's the case welcome
to another very nice game from round
four of the Sun wastages tournament it's
a game between Spanish grandmaster
Alvaro long so Russell and similar guard
the Grandmaster from France and you you
don't want to mistake him for maximal
agro of France I know it's a silly thing
to mention but if you're new to chess
and if you perhaps don't get to know who
everyone is then it might might happen
to you to mistake these two gentlemen
and even when I search for a nice photo
of him if you just google maximal guard
you will even have a couple of photos of
maxime beaugeois graphic
and also before we check out the actual
game I wanted to mention that well there
is this rap song and magnus carlsen
takes part in this song he has a well
short part maybe 40 seconds where he
wraps wraps out his part in Norwegian so
I will put a link to that song in the
description below feel free to check it
out
the entire song is in Norwegian the
quote above the board is also a part of
the song so do check it out
the time stamp for Magnus is part is I
think six minutes and 20 seconds but if
you understand Norwegian you are welcome
to check out the entire song as well as
so far it only has some 3,000 views so
feel free to you know check it out
comment like and whatnot so getting back
to our game it might be weird to be
showing a game from wrong for is already
round 10 has finished but I do have a
very nice reason for this and we are
gonna get back to that at the end of the
game so Oliver Alonso also has the white
pieces and he opens with d4 and it's
really gonna be really a wonderful game
Knight to f6
we have nice to f3 sorry about that
g6 g3 and Bishop to g7 so we have the
Indian game on the board push up the g2
about be able players feel Cairo that
Bishop's we have castles castles and d6
with b3 c5 challenging white center c4
and now you could go for something like
e five and then after D captures pawn
captures you could simply continue
developing go for a queen trade but here
black decides to play d5 it seems like
like a waste of a waste of a tempo but
such is the life of a player wielding
the black pieces you are a bunch to lose
at MP or or two here and there
Bishop to b2 I've been carrying the
other bishop as well C capture some d4
Knight captures on b4 and this is only
moon line this position has been reached
a few times before but the move played
in this game e5 is a new move and now we
have a completely new game on our hands
we have nice to f3 and now II for
forcing the Knights to choose where it's
going if you go ninety five you will
immediately lose the Knights to G for
this unfortunate pin will be favoring
black you cannot capture the two Bishop
captures and g2 also and b2 also the
roof will fall
so after efore we have Knights too deep
for and here black has a couple of very
nice options you can simply continue
developing either go developing with the
lights worship you can always capture on
c4 you can go night a6 but black
actually decides to go for e3 a very
nice pawn sacrifice so that if accepted
let's F captures on e3 you will go nice
the g4 put pressure on this e3 pawn your
bishop comes alive but after going to
see one you will for the moment defend
the e3 pawn but it's a very committal
position for white and not at all
enjoyable so after e3 we have F 3 white
decides the not not to capture the e3
pawn and we can already consider this a
small victory for black D captures on c4
and now comes Knight to a3 and here
black can't grab another pawn with pawn
captures but after Queen captures white
will get a lot of development and black
really hasn't even started developing
his pieces yet so not something you want
to do so black decides to hinder White's
development by giving back upon the way
black wants to at
c3l okay Bishop captures on c3 and now
comes Queen to e7 developing the queen
with a nice attack on the knight on a
three after the pieces are developed
maybe this even this rook can come into
the game a via an attack against the
dark square bishop Knights the c4 now
the night is no longer attacked we have
looked at the eight and now comes the
Queen to see one now getting the Queen
out of the D file that is occupied by
the rook on d8 but also putting pressure
on the e3 pawn Knight to d5 attacking
the bishop on c3 bishop moves we have
Bishop back to be two and here the best
and the best course of action for black
is to go to Knight d7 to b6
perhaps trade off this night on c4 and
then try a try and develop once this
Bishop is developed in this rook comes
to c8 black will be perfectly fine but
here black plays b6 opens up this
diagonal and it seems to be giving white
a bit too much white immediately opens
up his bishop we have f4 now the bishop
comes alive
Bishop the b7 countering the bishop on
this very nice diagonal and here white
again has a couple of very nice options
you can either proceed with f5 there's a
very little black can do about this but
we have a different move we have nice to
e5 and now well capturing the knight is
a possibility you don't want to give up
your very strong dragon here for this
knight on e5 as you will have very
little to oppose White's dark square
bishop with and also if you don't do it
then you have to do something about it
as nice to see 6 with a nice with a nice
fork is coming
so here Queen - it is played we have
looked at the 1 and here again you could
go for something like Bishop characters
on e5 in this position this would most
likely be the best course of action as
this Knight is now too powerful after
captures you will continue developing
bring to recover to c8 and you know
white will be better but you will still
be in the game here after Luke to d1 we
have a nice to a6 and now comes Knight
d2 c6 attacking the rook on d8 and here
again the best course of action is to
capture the night
Bishop captures now of course you don't
have time to capture the root because
the bishop captures here but you also
could do it sorry about that I don't
know why I hid that after Luke 2d 196 we
said rook to see it was played but now
after this the best course of action
yeah sorry about that we said Bishop
captures only five but now after Knight
captures and e8 you get Bishop captures
here Queen captures and now have to look
after sandy eight black would be black
would be excellent in this position so
in fact after Bishop captures only five
you would have to capture back Knight
captures on e5 and it's not something
you want to do now you're you don't have
your very strong dragon but it's still
it's still better than anything anything
else you could play let's say you
develop drug attack the Queen Knight now
goes back Knight c4 and the game
continues but here after Knight d2 c6 we
have look eight to see it and it seems
like a very reasonable move bringing
this rook into the game with temple not
with temple but well it kind of is with
tempo as the knight is attacked twice
you're threatening to nob capture the
knight on e5 which is the only useful
defender to the knight on c6
so it seems like a very nice move but
it's in fact the losing move so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the series of moves that win the
game for white as usual I'll give you a
couple of seconds for you to decide
whether you want to do it or not so you
don't feel free to do it I'm just gonna
have a nice sip of water here so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you you are the man or
or a woman as three three points um
three point five percent of my
subscribers are women and for those of
you who just want to enjoyed show the
move played in the game with Bishop
captures on d5 for fun we're just gonna
show if you decided to play Knight
captures on d8 it's also playable but
it's much more complicated and it's not
not at all clear if you will win the
game because after a series of forceful
Changez rook captures the queen the most
obvious one night capture some b7 and
now after Bishop captures Bishop
captures rook captures and Bishop
captures back Queen to c6 now but of
course you will save the knight bush of
character some dd5 attacks the Queen
also protects the night after the Queen
moves but then after Queen to c2 attacks
the rook rook moves and now Knight the
b4 attacks the bishop white is still
better and white is up material here of
course but it's still hard hard to play
most likely white will win this in some
a hundred more moves but it's not the
best move in that position after located
to see it the move that alvaro long so
Russell plate is Bishop captures on d5
and it's really a wonderful move because
what do you do here if you try something
like rook captures on d5 to remove the
defender of the c6 square it doesn't
work simply rook captures and now after
you captures here the knight can capture
back it's not a problem simply Knight
captures on c6 so what black did here
instead Bishop captures on e5 makes
sense then I displayed you can actually
capture with the knight and also you
have just removed the defender of the c6
Knight but this is what a white head and
head and stored Bishop captures on f7
this was the idea capture on d5 capture
on d5 and only then capture on f7 and
now if you play Queen captures on f7
then you get rook captures Cindy age
with check so the knight will no longer
be pinned Rose captures and now will
just snatch the rook and attack the
Queen and after Bishop captures Queen
captures you will have to move the Queen
Queen d7 and now after knife capture
screen captures you will have a rook
against tonight and with the black King
wide open it's a completely winning game
for white
so now after Bishop captures an f7 King
captures on f7 was played and now comes
Queen to c4 check I'm not a wonderful
move as it really shows how how colorful
a game this is if you walk with the
Queen Queen e6
then you get Knight captures on e5 with
check you cannot capture with the Queen
and well or would you want to but you
can still as the Queen is
spend so I have to remove the King King
e7 Bishop III check King moves back now
you get Luke captures and e8 another
very nice move and after the Queen is
captured
now you go rook to f8 check King to g7
and now B captures on c4 and there is a
very little you can do here rook the
rook to f7 is coming go you can try to
bring the Beast into the game that still
captures captures rook f7 and now you
will either have to give up this Queen
for the rook and the night and still you
will be left with a rook against the
bishop or you will move the King and
then suffer two rook captures on b7 and
which two rooks and the night against
the Queen
White will have an easily winning game
so after Queen c4 we have King to g7
trying to escape but now comes Bishop
captures on e5 with check King to h6
and now comes Luke captures on d8
finally well this is of course with an
attack against the black Queen rook
captures Knight captures on the 8th and
now we have Queen captures and EH this
move 27 and it was in this position that
French Grandmaster Maximo guard resigned
the game why did he resign
well it's white to move white can simply
play Queen to f7 and it is all over
there's very little you can do against
but there is nothing you can do against
the Queen to g7 check and nor is there a
way to block at one one possible idea is
Queen d5 try and offer an exchange here
and hope for white it doesn't have a
mating attack so you can deliver
checkmate yourself but what it does have
a meeting attack Queen g7 check King has
to move now comes Queen captures here
King has to move Queen captures here
King has to move and now either Queen to
h5 or f5 will be checkmate
so yeah after Queen captures and the
eight black resigned without even
waiting for whites to make a move which
is I don't know it's a it's a good thing
but also maybe maybe if it's your game
maybe you just want to wait for whites
to make a move because it was not once
in chess history that the whites and
made like a terrible blunder and in a
completely winning
so perhaps you know it doesn't cost you
anything except you know maybe it's
annoying to wait for opponent to make a
move in winning position but still it's
possible the for for you know
a mistake to happen but yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it and after
10 rounds of the summary sieges
tournament in that very nice place we
already shown as plenty of times but
there you have it just in case you
haven't seen it it's like we said a very
wide photo so I can show it in its
entirety so we do have to use the
special dragging effects after 10 rounds
other Alonzo Rose Russell won the
tournament with 8 points out of 10 with
some a lot of other players to follow
with seven and a half points I like
Dimitri on Drake in earnest winner Kiev
and vastly von Schuch and a few more
others I think as a seeker and also and
yeah I don't I don't know who else was
there but I think there were like seven
players with seven and a half points
so quite a convincing victory and I
chose this game since it's really nice
and features are very nice ending
sequence but yeah do be sure to check
out the Magnus rap song it will be the
first thing you will see in the
description below I would like to thank
Cecil Cooke James Norwood Selene Cole do
a drill Victoria Lopez and Martin shreya
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous video
so you're thankful for watching and I
will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content thank you all and I'll see you
soon